Democrats apparently running out of
Republicans to attack so they're turning
on each other
Alexandria Casa Cortez has been battling
back and forth with Nancy Pelosi and now
AOC is suggesting that Pelosi criticism
of her and other freshman Dems is racist
AOC saying the persistent singling out
it got to a point where it was just
outright disrespectful to explicit
singling out of newly elected women of
color
despite that smear Pelosi isn't backing
down but neither is AOC its singling out
for individuals and knowing the media
environment that were operating in
knowing the amount of death threats that
we get knowing the amount of
concentration of attention I think it's
just it's it's worth just worth asking
why do you think she has racial animus
is she race oh no absolutely
of course not Greg of course she did it
she just said that but didn't really
mean it I really wish I mean I I know
that one might disagree with me but I
want the best for the Democrats I really
do because I think that every party do I
do but I've every party benefits from a
strong competitor right I think that and
they always get better I know you don't
believe me I don't want this to happen I
don't want them to eat themselves alive
but in woke culture it's not about
cooperating or uniting it's about
delineating I'm not a person like you
I'm X Y & Z color orientation gender
disability all this it becomes you know
this intersectionality game of who's
better who's more oppressed and to win
you have to label everyone else
intolerance so what you're left with is
the tiniest party and it's a movement
this whole thing is based on narcissism
right who can be the most woke and get
the most attention and it's at the
expense of your allies so aoc insults
her and it was no question when you said
that she was she was targeting women of
color she was saying she was being a
racist so but she says that she's not so
what about what about that one in terms
of you know she pushes on Nancy Pelosi
and then she pulls back and while Nancy
Pelosi was trying to deal with her
member management problem well I think
this is bigger than Nancy Pelosi but let
me just say I don't I think she's very
clear this is absolutely not a claim
that Nancy Pelosi was racist and boy was
there blowback from Nancy Pelosi's
caucus in terms of blacks and Latinos
saying this is crazy look at how
this caucus is and that's because of
Nancy Pelosi mm-hmm and there was
blowback in terms of some of the
comments made about moderates especially
southern Democratic moderates thena and
some of those southern Democratic
moderates guess what they're blonde
right and they said wait a minute what
are you talking about right so I think
she's getting blowback within the caucus
but I think that part of this is that
you know people are reluctant we are
reluctant to talk about generational
divides in our country we like to talk
about race you know we can I just think
that's the opposite no I think we love
talking about generations no race we
don't by the way they would have to
Mayor P - they wouldn't have to mayor
Pete no hang on hey let me finish this
point they don't I think we as a country
do not say hey you know what there's a
huge generational divide in the country
and a huge generational divide among
Democrats with the younger part of the
country right now is mostly Democratic
heavily diverse in terms of race
immigrants and the like and the older
part of the Democratic Party is more I
think it's diverse but if they love
Bernie the young ones love Bernie
correct what is that point that my point
is generational I mean you've got
younger progressives are flocking to
Bernie not to mayor Pete so it's not
generational is what I'm saying I'm not
getting a bit let me say let me explain
it again okay the younger people might
in fact like a Bernie or like the more
progressive politics and a life but they
are really angry that the older folks as
they see it don't respond to the
bullying to the punching that comes from
President Trump they say hey how come
you guys don't fight like president and
why don't you punch back on one and the
older crowd saying hey I know how to
count votes on the House floor right I
know how to win elections all you guys
do is talk about clicks on Twitter yeah
she talks about called him the squad the
squad that elevates them by giving them
a nickname so I don't know if that was
the best technique one the older
Democrats tried to stage a coup against
the president I think they've been
fighting the president pretty damn hard
the last two years but I also strongly
disagree with Greg the Democratic Party
destroy itself eat itself alive they've
uncorked this bottle this virus this
identity politics virus and now it's
eating them and now they're upset about
it oh really you guys are upset because
the last five years
anytime you criticize Barack Obama
racist you criticize omar up
Islamophobic you criticize the cap to
the US soccer team sexist and homophobic
so you know what the chickens have come
home to roost to quote the pastor of
Barack Obama and it's sad because the
only time you play the race card in the
gender card is because you don't have
any cards left to play and that's what
you said right here when you cited this
Democratic lawmaker
she sounds like a Republican she's this
William lacy clay excuse me male
Democrat from Missouri what a weak
argument talking about aoc because you
can't get your way and because you're
getting pushed back you resort to using
the race card
that's unbelievable to me so that's what
Republicans have been saying for so long
that it's a weak response when you can't
persuade to make an argument and I will
say lastly they haven't been singled out
they singled themselves out they were
the only for people to vote while 240
others voted the other way and they've
all been lightning rods since they got
in they're always getting all the
attention
Nancy hasn't singled themselves they've
done it to themselves I'm gonna make a
point so the squad only has four votes
right now but they don't need that many
more votes in order to cause Nancy
Pelosi real headaches it would take
about 18 votes for them to not be able
to pass things so if people get
increasingly frustrated with the
establishment that could happen and
that's why I think it's important for
somehow there to be a balance of energy
and to me this entire thing is like you
know you go out to dinner with another
couple and then they get into an
argument in front of you and they're
bickering and it's just it's too icky it
makes everyone uncomfortable and to me
it's a joy I enjoy
do it like do it at home because to me
it's like a sorority squabble and more
than generational it's it's a maturity
difference - I agree the squad single
themselves out it's like they showed up
on the first day wearing the same
t-shirt and then are aghast at the
thought of kind of buddies and we wear
pink totally and so but I think
importantly moving forward that Pelosi
has to prove to her centrist districts
that AOC and the squad are not setting
the agenda and then also however she
needs to harness that energy like I said
in the beginning because otherwise she
could lose the speakership if the
Democrats do hold the house or maintain
the house moving forward so somehow they
have to figure it out but to me it's
better done behind closed doors
strategically rather than playing out
like a reality show
[Music]